bjbj 2011-09-12_wasteland [0:00:04] Martha
Minow: Good afternoon. If you don t have a
seat, please do take one. It is an enormous
pleasure for me to welcome you all here today
to this special event. I m Dean Martha Minow
here at Harvard Law School. A half century
ago, the 35-year-old federal regulator of
an agency most people had never heard of woke
up the public with a searing speech that to
this day is studied in rhetoric courses. It
s used in headlines. I happen to know it s
used on a LSAT reading comprehension test
and it is used in persistent assessments of
how communications technology affects entertainment
and news, culture and democracy. In 1961,
Newton Minow, appointed by President John
F. Kennedy to chair the Federal Communications
Commission told the National Association of
Broadcasters, When television is good, nothing,
not the theater, not the magazines or newspapers,
nothing is better. But when television is
bad, nothing is worse. I invite each of you
to sit down in front of your television set
when you station goes on the air and stay
there for a day without a book, without a
magazine, without a newspaper, without a profit
and loss sheet or a rating book to distract
you. Keep your eyes glued to that set until
the station signs off. And here it comes,
I can assure you that what you will observe
is a vast wasteland, borrowing from T.S. Eliot
s great poem. Newton Minow challenged American
broadcasters actually to watch the shows that
they were putting out on the public air waves,
the game shows, the violence, the boredom;
and he shocked a complacent industry. He called
for imagination, excellence and creativity.
Fifty years later, we bring him here to meet
with the amazingly imaginative, excellent
and creative individuals who will participate
in today s program. They include remarkable
people from the Berkman Center for Internet
and Society which is rooted here in the law
school while reaching the university and the
world, extraordinary journalists who will
explore with us where we are now, a vaster
wasteland or a new greatness when it comes
to entertainment and news, policy makers,
other former regulators, imaginative theorists.
You are in for a treat, those of you who are
here. I want to give my personal thanks to
the participants from the Berkman Center,
John Palfrey, Terry Fisher, Yochai Benkler,
Jonathan Zittrain, Urs Gasser and so many
others who made this event happen. You are
all stars and I give special thanks to all
of you. m so pleased also to welcome Ann Marie
Lipinski here and also to Harvard, now the
head of the Nieman Foundation which co-sponsors
this event. She s a Pulitzer Prize winning
journalist and active participant in constructing
new models of non-profit newsgathering and
distribution and she brings the eye of a writer,
the judgment of an editor and the wisdom of
someone who has survived the tumult in both
the newspaper business and the academic world.
Jonathan Alter will also be here. He has been
described as the most astute political observer
in his generation. He too an award-winning
and best-selling author, now at Bloomberg
News after 28 years at Newsweek and on Twitter
I happen to know personally. Susan Crawford,
expert on internet governance and information
regulation. Perry Hewitt, expert on the digital
world and social networking. Nicholas Negroponte,
the remarkable, inspiring figure from the
MIT Media Lab and the One Laptop per Child
initiative. Tim Wu, whose studies of information
empires have rocked the world anew. Ellen
Goodman, information analyst par excellence.
I am so thrilled you re all here and I promise
I will sit down in a second so the discussion
really starts but I do have a point of personal
privilege which takes me back to Newton Minow.
A veteran of World War Two, Minow learned
the significance of global communication during
his service in the China Burma India Theater
during that war. He built a career spanning
law, politics, the academy and business while
helping to build and criticize the [0:05:00]
news communication world. He has chaired the
Public Broadcasting Service. He helped to
fund Sesame Street. He has advised networks
and cable companies. He s an architect and
statesman of the presidential debates televised
and video streamed on the internet in this
country for decades, of counsel to the law
firm Sidley Austin Brown and Wood, long time
university professor at Northwestern University.
He is the husband of Jo Minow who is here
today and they are my beloved parents. T.S.
Eliot who gave dad the phrase vast wasteland
also said, It is in fact a part of the function
of education to help us to escape, not from
our own time for we are bound by that, but
from the intellectual and emotional limitations
of our time. I look forward to this session
in precisely that spirit and I m delighted
to welcome Newton Minow here to Harvard Law
School. [Applause] Newton Minow: Thank you,
Martha. What greater honor can a father have
than to have his daughter say some nice things
about him, even if they re not true? I also
thank our son who is here, Joe Singer. I don
t call him my son-in-law. Martha s husband,
a distinguished faculty member; and a dear
friend surprised me by coming here today,
Doris Kearns Goodwin. Doris, you [Applause]
Newton Minow: If you haven t read her book
about Lincoln, you must. President Obama has
it at his bedside. I m very much an admirer
of the Berkman Center. It s the first of its
kind that I know of in this country and its
work is not only substantive. It s creative.
It s imaginative. It s highly respected. I
wish it had existed when I was chairman of
the FCC. I knew the Berkman family. They were
broadcasters when I was at the FCC in Ohio.
They had a very high sense of the public interest
and public service. When I agreed to come
here today, I hadn t focused on the date.
I didn t realize it was going to be one day
after 9/11 and like all of you, yesterday
was a very emotional one for me. Our firms
and New York office was in the World Trade
Center. We had 677 people there and when it
was all over, the office manager got everyone
to the first floor and we said, Fortunately,
we only lost one person, a receptionist who
somehow disappeared after they got to the
first floor. Today, we say, Unfortunately
we lost one person. Also [0:08:26] [Indiscernible]
was a member of the board of directors of
the Aon Corporation which had 900 people in
the building and lost 177; and yesterday,
I read in the Chicago Tribune at home an interview
with the former CEO of Aon who said he was
brought to tears this week when he got two
letters. One from a freshman at Columbia University,
one from a freshman at Tufts thanking Aon
for making it possible to have scholarships
for all the children of those who died there.
So it s something really to think about. In
terms of communications, do you realize that
10 years ago there was no YouTube video? Ten
years ago, there were no cameras and cell
phones. Ten years ago, there were no tweets.
There was no Twitter. That was 10 years ago.
Then let s talk about 50 years ago when most
of you were not even born. What was it like
for me as a young person to be sent by President
Kennedy to the Federal Communications Commission?
At that time, phone calls went by wire. [0:10:00]
Broadcasting went through the air. Today,
as Professor Negroponte has pointed out, something
we should have all seen, until he observed
it himself, most phone calls go through the
air and most people get their television service
either by wire or by satellite. It had been
a fundamental basic transformation in the
world of communications and yet, there have
been very little thinking about what that
really means. In 1961, there were two and
a half television networks. There was one
telephone company. There were no personal
computers. There was no public television.
There was no public radio. FM radio was dormant.
Cable was fledgling. There was no internet
and usually, there was only one television
set in a home. It was a small black and white
set and the entire family watched the same
program at the same time. Audience was passive.
They listened or watched silently. There were
scandals in the broadcasting industry, bad
scandals in the 50s involving payola, involving
scams of various kinds. There were scandals
at the FCC. President Kennedy s predecessor,
President Eisenhower, had to fire the chairman
of the FCC for improper conduct. [0:11:49]
[Indiscernible] the industry and the agency
were both in bad trouble. On May 5th of that
year, there was a great triumph, the successful
launch of the first American in space, Commander
Alan Shepard. On May 8th, Shepard returned
from space and he came to see President Kennedy
in his office and they were then going to
go to congress. On the same day, President
Kennedy was to speak to the National Association
of Broadcasters and he had called and invited
me to ride with him to his speech and I was
to meet him outside the Oval Office. I was
waiting for him. President Kennedy came out
and he said, Newt. He said, The Shepards are
here. He said, What do you think about taking
them to the broadcasters convention? I said,
That would be perfect. That would mean everything.
He said, Well, and wait a minute. He said,
Let me go in and arrange it and I ll come
back and I ll get you. He came back out and
he said, OK, it s all set. Come with me though.
I want to change my shirt. So he took me upstairs
to the living quarters of the White House
and even though I had known the president
before, I was scared to death. Here I was
with the president of the United States, watching
him change his shirt and he said to me he
said, What do you think I should say to the
broadcasters? as if he hadn t given it any
thought before; and I said, I think you ought
to tell them the difference between a free
society and a closed society. The Soviets
sent people into space but you really never
know if it was successful or it wasn t. There
was no radio and television there to cover
it but in our country, we let everybody see
and hear what was going on. So you ought to
talk about what the contribution broadcasting
made to our citizens to understand this new
world. The president didn t say anything.
He didn t say that s good or that s bad. He
finished changing his shirt. We went downstairs
and took me in the Oval Office and there were
Commander Shepard and his wife and there was
Vice President Johnson. We were all going
to go together and we went, walked out to
the driveway and I thought I would get in
the second car because now we had the Shepards
and the vice president. The president says,
No, no, no. He says, Newt, come on. Just get
in the jump seat. He said, Lyndon, you get
in the other jump seat, and he put the Shepards
in the backseat with himself; and we drove
through Rock Creek Park up to what was then
called the Wardman Park Hotel. It s now called
the Sheraton Park Hotel and the president
was in a very ebullient mood. This was after
the failure of the Bay of Pigs. Here is something
that had gone right. We had a success. We
were catching up with the Russians so he slapped
Lyndon on the shoulder and he said, Lyndon,
you are the chairman of the [0:15:00] National
Space Council, and the vice president said,
Yes. The president said, Yes, but nobody knows
that Lyndon. But he said, I guarantee you,
Lyndon. If this had been a failure, if that
space shot had been a failure, I would have
seen to it that everybody [Laughter] Newton
Minow: Lyndon didn t laugh and I [Laughter]
Newton Minow: But I was next to him at the
other jump seat and unfortunately, I have
a big mouth. I couldn t resist it. So I said,
Mr. President. I said, If it had been a failure,
the vice president would have been the next
astronaut. [Laughter] Newt Minow: Which the
vice president didn t think was very funny
either. [Laughter] Newt Minow: When we got
there, the president gave a three-minute,
perfectly-timed, a perfectly-phrased speech
about the difference between a free society
and a closed society, about how broadcasting
had allowed every American to see what was
going on. He got a standing ovation. The next
day, I came to speak and I think the broadcaster
wished I had changed my shirt because there
was no standing ovation. Now why did I give
that speech? Television had become, in 1961,
the dominant form of communication in our
country. Everybody could afford it and that
was most people had a television set. The
Kennedy-Nixon debate on television in 1960
had, in my opinion and in the opinion of President
Kennedy, decided the election. Television
had become extremely important but there had
been very little discussion or debate in the
country about what that meant in terms of
public responsibility, public interest and
I was determined even though I knew that my
speech would not be welcomed. My favorite
response was from a man named Sherwood Schwartz
who was the producer of a program called Gilligan
s Island. He sent me a message because he
named the sinking ship after me, the S.S.
Minnow. [Laughter] Newt Minow: But I knew
what I was getting into and now that was 50
years ago and what I decided the government
s role should be and this is what I hope we
ll get into here. The government s role, I
felt, was to expand choice, to open up new
channels. We opened up the UHF channels. We
asked congress to pass a bill that required
that every television set could tune into
a UHF channel which quintupled the number
of television channels. We opened up cable.
Satellites were discovered. President Kennedy
took me on a tour of the space program and
he said to me, Why do you think these communication
satellites are so important? And I said, Mr.
President, they re more important than sending
a man into space. He said, Why is that? I
said, Communication satellites will send ideas
into space and ideas last longer than people.
Communication satellites have fundamentally
changed we can see what s going on all over
the world and they can see us. All the things
that are happening in the Middle East, many
people believe, are really caused by the explosion
in satellite communication. I felt it was
a disgrace that we had no public television.
I came to the FCC from Chicago where we had
channel 11, a public station. President Kennedy
came from Boston where there was WGBH. In
our ignorance, we thought every city had a
public television station. We found out there
was none in New York City, the largest city
in the country. There was none in Los Angeles,
the second largest city in the country. There
was none in Washington D.C., the nation s
capital. So we decided something had to be
done about that and we ve succeeded. Congress
passed the first legislation that helped create
public television. We got stations going in
New York and Los Angeles and Washington and
I felt that after two years, I was going broke.
Martha was and her sisters. Martha was six
years old. Her sisters were [Laughter] Newt
Minow: [0:20:00] Her older and younger sisters.
I was I couldn t afford it anymore so I had
promised President Kennedy I would be there
for two years. Two years to the day, I asked
for an appointment to see him. I walked in.
The president said, re the only guy I brought
here who never asked to see me. I know what
you want. You want to go home. I said, That
s right, Mr. President. I can t afford it.
He says, Are you sure you don t want another
job? I said, So I left but I felt I had accomplished
a lot. After I left the government, I have
had a blessed life. I was chairman of the
Public Broadcasting Service and was able to
build that system into what it is today. I
served on the board of CBS with Walter Cronkite
when the giants were still there. I served
on the board of the Tribune Company. Ann Marie
Lipinski, Pulitzer Prize winner when the Tribune
was winning Pulitzer Prizes instead of being
in bankruptcy. I was fortunate to serve and
then become chairman of the Carnegie Foundation
which was a basic funder for a public broadcasting.
So I ve had a blessed, fortunate life but
the most important thing that I want to urge
a discussion about today is the future, not
the past. Thomas Jefferson said he liked the
dreams of the future more than he liked thinking
about the past. Today you have a different
world. My grandchildren tell me they don t
even have television sets. What they watched
is on their computer. You can carry your iPad
around and see what s going on. The internet
is absolutely one of the most important inventions
of all time. There again I was lucky. I was
on the board of the Rand Corporation when
the first work was done to create the internet
under a contract for the government. People
forget this. The government funded what is
today we call the internet. There was a contract
led up by the Department of Defense and Rand
developed what s called packet switching and
that now is the guts of enabling the internet
to work. m disappointed particularly today
by the media and politics and I hope we will
get to discuss this. Today s politics is dominated
by money. Most candidates spend most of their
time raising money. Why do they need the money?
They need the money so they can buy radio
and television time. So they re buying they
re raising money from the public to get access
to something the public owns, the airwaves.
That s a crazy system. We re one of the few
countries in the world that does not provide
public service time to candidates. In England,
you cannot if you re a candidate, you cannot
purchase time. It s not allowed. That s true
in Japan. That s true in many countries in
Asia. It s true in Europe and we go with a
system where the politics and the cost of
campaigning is really caused by the media.
So I hope in our discussion now, I ve talked
long enough, we ll talk about that and we
ll talk about many other issues. The Berkman
Center, I wish it existed 50 years ago. I
heard a talk today. Some of the people from
the Berkman were there. The Knight Foundation
happens to be in town at Harvard and they
had a senior adviser to the FCC talking about
these issues and I said to him, I wish 50
years ago, we had the benefit of the brains
dealing with these questions. When television
was developed in this country, the word television
was not even added to the Communications Act
for 30 years. There was no debate in this
country. There was no discussion of the public
responsibility. It has been neglected and
I hate to say it, it s neglected today. Thank
you. [Applause] Jonathan Zittrain: Newt, thank
you so much for these opening remarks and
provocations. [0:25:00] It does seem like
you ve been sort of a hyper intelligent Forrest
Gump sort of in the present or the maybe the
a Zelig we might say depending on our choice
of popular culture references but incredible
that you ve been there for so much and been
such an actor amidst it too. As Martha said,
this is one of those original speeches that
was said to have such an impact on the public
discourse and what came later and it demonstrates
Mark Twain s admonition to us. Everybody is
always talking about the weather but nobody
ever does anything about it and you ve been
doing something about the weather so Female
Speaker: Well, I got to go home [0:25:39]
[Phonetic]. Jonathan Zittrain: Fair enough.
I ll stop the praise right now on advice of
the counselor wife and instead, invite down
our three respondents to respond briefly to
the provocation, to say a few things. So Ann
Marie Lipinski, Jonathan Alter and Yochai
Benkler, come on down. Like game shows is
one of the things you didn t like but it does
have that sort of feel to it. So great to
meet you. Thank you. Jonathan Alter: Nice
to meet you. Jonathan Zittrain: Please have
a seat. Very pleased to meet you. Ann Marie
Lipinski: Nice to meet you. Jonathan Zittrain:
Hi. So, Ann Marie, why don t we start with
you? You are the curator-designate of the
Nieman Foundation. Tell us what that means.
Ann Marie Lipinski: m the actual curator.
Jonathan Zittrain: Oh, no longer the curator-designate.
Wikipedia has fallen behind, it seems. [Laughter]
Jonathan Zittrain: Could somebody Male Speaker:
ll fix that right away. Jonathan Zittrain:
Yes, we re fixing that right now. [Laughter]
Jonathan Zittrain: I should also say speaking
of dynamic, the things this has been webcast
so it s going out through the satellites into
the ether. Who knows what s going to happen
to it next. So if for some reason you don
t want to be captured on film, first, don
t say anything. It would draw attention and
other, you might actually want to leave the
room completely; but other than that, if you
are on Twitter, on the opposite side of things
and would like to be noticed, we have decided
that perhaps hashtag vast wasteland would
be the right Twitter tag for this event. Anyway,
Ann Marie, you were saying Ann Marie Lipinski:
Yes. Jonathan Zittrain: you are currently
the curator at the Nieman Foundation. Just
tell us what that means and then feel free
to lead right into your response. Ann Marie
Lipinski: So it I have no paintings that I
m in charge of but I am in charge of a program
about journalism and it is one of Harvard
s great contributions. It s a program that
has been here for 75 years endowed by the
family that owned the paper in Milwaukee and
their idea was to bring to Harvard people
uniquely unqualified [0:27:47] [Phonetic]
for journalism, whatever that meant and means,
and to give them access to this amazing institution
for a year to grow as journalists and thereby
improve the profession. Jonathan Zittrain:
So you get to fill the box of chocolates.
Ann Marie Lipinski: I do and I have some of
the chocolates here tonight. A bunch of my
fellows are in the room. So, can I tell one
quick story on the Minows? Jonathan Zittrain:
Of course, of course. Ann Marie Lipinski:
So you saw tonight why we love Newt. So he
s a great storyteller and language is very
important to him and narrative is very important
to him which is why we pay attention. It s
not just ideas. It s the way he conveys and
compels those ideas but one I a couple of
years ago, I was actually sitting shiva with
him on the near north side of Chicago and
he started one of these stories with me. It
was something that went on for sometime and
I was of course wrapped and waiting for every
you know, the next word but Jo was waiting
to go home. So this went on for some time
with her, you know, politely yanking at his
sleeve and she finally just utterly frustrated
said, Hey, Mr. Vast Wasteland, I want to go
home. [Laughter] Jonathan Zittrain: I got
to say though, among the compliments, to say
that someone is a good man to sit shiva with,
that s a [Laughter] Jonathan Zittrain: That
s a compliment. Ann Marie Lipinski: Jonathan
Zittrain: Those of you who don t know it,
you can Google it. Yes. [Laughter] Ann Marie
Lipinski: But there is an important point
which is I mean, you know, Newt said a lot
of important things tonight as he has been
saying for years but one of them was, you
know, telling President Kennedy that sending
ideas into space was more important than sending
men into space and what you know, therein
lies this great notion of his which is the
technology is meaningless, right, without
the content and his ability to really inspire
with language and the way these ideas are
infused with this amazing poetry. Vast wasteland,
you know, was a term that sort of existed
in one realm and that 50 years later, [0:30:00]
you know, after Gilligan s Island and Dark
Shadows and all the things that, you know,
polluted my youth, that we re still talking
about that and still inspired by those ideas
and taking that and thinking about it in terms
of other media. I think it s really, really
provocative and something he didn t say is
that he s also I mean still all these years
later, working on new models of journalism.
He is one of the founding board members of
the Chicago News Cooperative which was his
when I left the paper, you know, he called
me instantly not to say anything other than,
I have the next job for you, because he was
already imagining what came next for American
journalism and it s just you know, his use
of really poetic language to elevate those
ideas, I think, is something that has been
lost a lot when we talk about how provocative
that speech was and it s a great lesson for,
you know, journalists everywhere. Jonathan
Zittrain: And one thing Newt has been known
to somewhat rue [0:30:54] [Phonetic] is that
that evocative language is the bumper sticker
from the speech. Rather he has said then the
phrase public interest which is much less
evocative but perhaps Ann Marie Lipinski:
Well, it you know, it s the tyranny of the
headline writer. It made it Jonathan Zittrain:
Yes. Ann Marie Lipinski: I believe it was
the page one headline in the New York Times
which is the next morning, which is why we
re all using it today; but actually there
s something in that speech and I don t know
what he thinks. One of the most inspirational
paragraphs to me is where he says he basically
looks at the room and he says, Is there a
man in this room who doesn t believe they
can do better? I mean to ask that of anybody
and anything they do and to me, that s a powerful
moment and then I think sort of funny. He
says next, Let me ask it another way. Is there
a broadcaster in this room who thinks that
the broadcaster next to them can t do better?
But if you ask that about your work, any of
us, can we not do better tomorrow? Who among
us would say we cannot? Jonathan Zittrain:
Yes. Ann Marie Lipinski: And I actually I
mean that s the part of the speech that I
actually find the most demanding and the most
insistent that I ve recollected Jonathan Zittrain:
And finally in the year since for the public
interest piece of it, do you feel like there
s a consensus around what that means when
it is and isn t being served, when you are
doing better and when you re not Ann Marie
Lipinski: Jonathan Zittrain: or is it a personal
standard Ann Marie Lipinski: It would be interesting
to hear Newt or somebody talk about the extent
to which there was agreement about what public
interest meant then. My sense is we know less
what that means now, that there are fewer
and fewer people who would define that in
the same way and I don t think it s a shared
ethos in the society. Jonathan Zittrain: Jonathan
Alter, why don t we turn to you? There was
an invitation in Newt s remarks to think about
politics and television and media. You wrote
The Promise: President Obama, Year One and
I guess you followed the campaign through
thick and thin. That would be at least one
angle to start with but if there s anything
else we don t know about you biographically,
we won t lean on Wikipedia. We ll lean on
you. Feel free to tell us and then respond
as you like. Jonathan Alter: Well, maybe the
most relevant is that I m from Chicago and
I essentially grew up with the Minows in one
fashion or another so there s a bit of nepotism
at work here today perhaps. Anybody who has
small children or nieces and nephews and wants
a good book for them, I recommend Jo Minow
s books. They re also about my favorite vegetable,
the artichoke so and so I have just left Newsweek
after 28 years there and I work now I write
in addition to books, I m writing a column
for Bloomberg View which is a new commentary
website that was just launched by Bloomberg;
and for, I guess, eight years or so in the
80s, I was Newsweek s media critic and I used
Newt Minow as a I think now he can tell now
it can be told, was an important source for
me is his many connections throughout the
media. A couple of things that he was too
modest to mention. The most important is that
he is the father of the presidential debate
and the televised presidential debate. I think
casual students of history believe that Lincoln
was the first one to debate but those were
in a senate campaign and what actually happened
was there were no radio debates [0:35:00]
in the 20th century between major party candidates.
In 1956, when Adlai Stevenson who was a very
close associate of Newt Minow was running
for president, the democratic nominee, and
Newt was one of his two or three closest aids,
Newt sent him a memo saying there should be
debates, televised debates; and Stevenson,
you know, kind of shopped it around and nobody
was quite ready for it. But four years later,
1960, they picked up on Newt s idea and Kennedy
and Nixon had their historic debates then
they had a 16-year gap when there were no
presidential debates and they resumed again
in 1976. But they had not yet been institutionalized
as a permanent part of our process and so
Newt chaired a commission on presidential
debates which he was kind enough to invite
me to participate in and we met here at Harvard
people from the media broadcasting the political
parties and set up the structure that now
exists for the sponsorship of televised presidential
debates. I think we can say if it hadn t been
for his pushing for them, we would probably
not have that as part of our system right
now. The other thing, he mentioned his corporate
board memberships, which those of you who
will become corporate lawyers will no doubt
be members of corporate boards; but I think
that his career in total is emblematic of
something that George H.W Bush said once which
is that no career is complete without service
to others and public service. If you, you
know, come back here for your 50th law school
reunion and, you know, maybe the way people
are living now, maybe you will be back for
your 75th law school reunion and you haven
t been doing anything else other than representing
your clients and making some money and helping
your already wealthy clients get wealthier.
I m sorry to sound like an Old Testament figure
but you have failed. You just you can t go
through life and do that without some kind
of deep involvement in your community either
through serving in the government or being
heavily involved as Newt and Jo have been
in a wide variety of other things and I know
that most of you will do that. So I don t
mean to be so censorious about it but he hadn
t mentioned these other things. Now just very
briefly in terms of the future which Newt
challenged us to look to, to me, the central
problem right now in the news business and
thereby in politics by extension and communications
by extension and in our democracy is that
the business model of the news business, which
is the only business that is recognized by
the US constitution explicitly, the business
model is now dysfunctional; and the reason
that it s dysfunctional is not that there
aren t some people who are making money. It
s that talk is cheap and reporting is expensive
so the vast wasteland now has this big Tower
of Babel on top of it. All right? Jonathan
Zittrain: You really are going biblical on
us Jonathan Alter: s a mixed metaphor. I m
going biblical. I m going biblical big time.
So, you know, every time you turn on the TV,
it s not like when there was when Newt was
head of the FCC, 15 minutes of news a night.
It wasn t until 1963 that NBC and CBS went
to a half hour. There was no 60 minutes. You
basically couldn t find news. Now we re lousy
with news . But what kind of news is it? It
s people like me babbling on MSNBC or Fox
or CNN or wherever and that the reporting
which is what a demographic society needs,
the fresh information that it needs, is really
expensive. It costs the New York Times like
a million dollars a year to have a bureau
in Baghdad, to actually find out what s really
going on and we ve developed and I hate to
sell like an old fogy on this but especially
some of the young reporters that I see. They
ve developed the sense that they don t actually
have to go somewhere or pick up the telephone
in order to report new information. That they
can find it all [0:40:00] online and you can
find a lot online but there s an awful lot
that you can t find out unless you report
it. See it with your own eyes and ears. Call
somebody up on a telephone and ask them questions
that they might not want to hear. Sometimes
they will respond by email but usually you
have to talk to them. So the question I have
is, If talk is cheap and reporting is expensive,
how are we going to get not the information
that we need but the knowledge and quality
content to make rational decisions in a democratic
society? and I don t have an answer. Jonathan
Zittrain: Since you have just framed that
question so well and we have special guests
whom we ll be calling upon as well, let s
just work it in right with the flow. Ethan
ve been looking at Ethan Zuckerman who originated
a venture called Global Voices, tagline The
world is talking. Are you listening? and I
m curious whether you see something like Global
Voices as fitting in the constitutional description
of the press that Jonathan was talking about
or is it the Tower of Babel about which he
has complained? Ethan Zuckerman: Well, I hope
that we re not contributing all that much
to the Tower of Babel although it s certainly
a possibility. Look, I actually largely agree
with Jonathan s points there. I think that
there s an enormous crisis going on in international
reporting and I think what s so ironic about
this is that we re at a moment where it should
be so much easier to report from around the
globe. There s this enormous amount of video
being filmed, being put online and it s not
all being put together by professional journalism.
It s being put together by amateurs. Some
of it is being put together by bloggers. It
needs a great deal of translation. It needs
a great deal of curation to be helpful and
I think what s really interesting is that
we re at a moment in time where one model
has sort of decayed. We haven t come up with
the next model. I m actually pretty optimistic
that the next model can come along and leverage
some of these opened networks that Newt Minow
has been involved with and that many of the
people in this room are deeply passionate
about but I also think it happens automatically.
I think taking very seriously this notion
that we may find ourselves reduced to the
least common denominator with the news media,
which is frankly talking heads rather than
going through the very hard work of contextualizing
either original reporting from the ground
or citizen reporting from the ground; because
it s hard work no matter what you do with
any of that. But what I think was very interesting
is as you were reacting there, Dave Marash
who a long time broadcast journalist, fairly
recently the US anchor for Al Jazeera, just
wrote a really remarkable piece in the Columbia
Journalism Review. One of the first things
he says in it is that we are seeing the emergence
of a universal human language and that s video
and I think that s absolutely right. I think
getting to the point where individuals are
able to create and disseminate video at almost
zero cost has just unprecedented power in
bridging between different corners of the
world. I think a lot of what happens in Tahrir
Square and people s ability to watch along
had to do with the power of the moving image
and I m struck by going back to Newt Minow
s speech and thinking about the notion that
television at its best really is better than
almost any other medium we have. Video really
is phenomenally and strongly powerful but
it needs some help and it needs translation
and it needs curation and it needs contextualization;
and trying to figure out how we do that in
the context of a new media environment is
one of the giant challenges that organizations
like mine have and frankly the news media
as a whole Jonathan Alter: Can I just respond
very quickly? Ethan Zuckerman: [0:44:09] [Inaudible]
Jonathan Alter: I think that you re spot on
with that and it is very exciting what social
media is doing and citizen journalism around
the world may be the most exciting thing in
global politics. But one of the things that
s missing is not just the context that editing
brings that you mentioned but also the connective
tissue between the images that we see and
that move us and political and social change.
So there was that image in Iran for instance
in 2009 of the woman dying in the streets
that went everywhere in the world and really
grabbed people s attention in an important
way and was an example of the international
language that you re talking about but it
didn t lead to any change in Iran. It did
in Egypt in maybe an [0:45:00] attenuated
way but investigative reporting which if somebody
was on the front page of the New York Times
just to give you a recent example. There was
a great story about how there are chemotherapy
drugs that there are shortages of them and
so it used to be that a story like that would
appear and then very quickly, the action to
address what the story raised. That s just
not happening as much now and we re not seeing
as many positive outcomes from good journalistic
work, social outcome. Jonathan Zittrain: I
guess when everything is a crisis every hour
Jonathan Alter: Yes. Jonathan Zittrain: your
outraged reservoir is totally drained. Jonathan
Alter: That s part of it. Jonathan Zittrain:
And then you re just like Jonathan Alter:
Yes. Jonathan Zittrain: yes, I knew it. No
chemotherapy drugs. Jonathan Alter: Right.
Jonathan Zittrain: Of course that s the state
of the world. Jonathan Alter: Right. Jonathan
Zittrain: Right, that kind of thing. Yochai,
I think it might make sense to turn next to
you because you ve been thinking hard both
about the structure of networks, the pipes,
how to grant equal access to them; and of
course the end for which that is a means is
to give voices to lots of people that might
not otherwise have them and to append the
industrial information economy that I think
may be what Jonathan was thinking of when
he was thinking about some of the traditional
press in its profession. So I m curious with
your take on this. Yochai Benkler: So, just
to start, it s a real pleasure and honor to
be able to have this conversation and have
this conversation with you. It s rare that
you have an instance that so captures an entire
era of policy and regulation and that everybody
can anchor themselves and say this is what
we re talking about, one generation after
another. But actually related to that, I want
to pick a different less poetic piece from
that speech that I think captures and hasn
t quite been raised yet but is really responsive
to your point, Jonathan, about it takes money
too and it goes roughly like this. This is
again a quote from the Vast Wasteland Speech.
Tell your sponsors to be less concerned with
cost per thousands and more concerned with
understanding per millions and remind your
stockholders that investment in broadcasting
is buying a share in public responsibility.
The networks can start this industry on the
road to freedom from the dictatorship of numbers.
That core tension between the American broadcast
model and the American media model that is
fundamentally anchored in [0:47:43] [Indiscernible]
and the American belief that this is supposed
to serve as the network for the state has
been there. It has been there from journalism
before television. It has been there, here.
That tension is what makes the possibility
of a public response. I mean the founding
public television, the idea that you can actually
have public funding but also non-profit funding
as a core of the way in which we produce news
is really quite alien to Americans, I think.
We have public television but at the same
time, people will say, Well, if there s government
funding, there will be too much influence,
ignoring the fact that the BBC presents the
best breed of news reporting in television
and nonetheless it s publicly-funded. There
are such models. They re just intention with
the way we do things here. I think one of
the things that the net enables, and I think
Ethan was pushing in that direction and you
came back with a no but you still need something
that costs a lot of money, is that the model
of production for the first time allows for
radically-distributed production, right? There
s a reason that the video you saw of Neda
Agha Soltan from Iran was a video from someone
on the street. The newspapers couldn t get
there. Jonathan Alter: Right. Yochai Benkler:
They were excluded. The fact that a hundred
thousand besiege were able to beat down a
revolution doesn t mean that the reporting
wasn t critical. Otherwise, we wouldn t know
about it and it turned out to inspire enough
that it did matter in Tahrir. It did matter
in Tunis. Last week in the iLaw seminar we
had here for a week, Ethan was sitting there
telling the story of what happened before
Egypt in Tunisia and how much of what you
have is this complex interaction between on
one hand people on the ground. On the other
hand, people who are on the diaspora again
on a non-profit political basis building what
they build and talking with each other and
then ultimately going to Al Jazeera, a publicly-funded
[0:50:00] source to generalize. So, I think
what s critical is to see that for the first
time, because of the fact that we all hold
in our hands image capture equipment, sound
recording equipment, writing equipment, distribution
on generally available platforms that are
consumer-grade platforms like YouTube as opposed
to a satellite link that needs to cost who
knows how much, we actually have the opportunity
to solve this tear between what requires a
lot of money and what we need as citizens.
That s not dependent on something that is
so difficult for the American political system
and American cultural system to swallow which
is public funding, at least not public funding
at a level that is really solve the whole
problem. Jonathan Alter: Right, and I just
very briefly, I think that s exactly right
and that s why I m also optimistic generally
because of what you just said; but it depends
on a new marketplace and ideas and it depends
on that marketplace working. So that the quality,
you know, tweets so there s some relationship
between how many followers you have and how
good your tweets are or some relationship
between how many people are reading your blog
and how good your blog is and I do think that
is starting to happen in particular subsets
of media and that s a very positive development
but it does depend on quality it depends on
a model where quality brings enough eyeballs
that it can be Jonathan Zittrain: It sounds
like you re saying there s a clear market
for paparazzi, like that s not a Jonathan
Alter: Right. TMZ Jonathan Zittrain: business
model that s in trouble. Jonathan Alter: s
not in trouble. Jonathan Zittrain: But it
s not clear that the market for revelations
about chemotherapy drugs is still sustainable.
Jonathan Alter: Well, it might be because
you might be able to get the chemotherapy
drug companies advertising on that site, you
know. So there are Jonathan Zittrain: Not
enough drugs Jonathan Alter: a lot of yes.
Jonathan Zittrain: Right. Jonathan Alter:
There are a lot of other, you know, creative
possibilities Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. Jonathan
Alter: for underwriting that Jonathan Zittrain:
Yes. Jonathan Alter: kind of coverage but
then you have questions that needs to be independent
of the advertising. Jonathan Zittrain: Yes.
Jonathan Alter: And those are very old questions
Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. Jonathan Alter: in
our business. Jonathan Zittrain: Independence
from Yochai Benkler: Jonathan Zittrain: Sorry.
Go ahead. Yochai Benkler: I would resist the
notion that the sine qua non of quality is
many eyeballs that can sell a lot, right?
It s the interface between Jonathan Alter:
Right. Yochai Benkler: very different systems,
right? So we have you know, if you want to
look at media [0:52:38] [Indiscernible], you
have things like Media Matters and FactCheck.org
that are Jonathan Alter: Right. Yochai Benkler:
public interest, located in universities based
on the modeling which we produce all sorts
of scholarship, all sorts of public goods
that are public interest. Alongside something
that is non-profit like ProPublica alongside
the New York Times and so the mix between
them. So I saw the story on Zanzibar on Global
Voices before I saw it here and there was
context from somebody who was over there and
actually writing. That s because there s someone
there who cares about it. I think the reemergence
of the party presses both left and right in
the blogosphere tells you that there are people
who are going to be out there and trying to
ferret all sorts of things. Jonathan Alter:
Is that a good thing to go to a European or
19th century model of party press? That Yochai
Benkler: If people would care about enough
to go and look for political information,
teach themselves, teach each other, absolutely
it s a good thing. If people come together
to speak together, absolutely it s a good
thing. [Crosstalk] [0:53:37] Ann Marie Lipinski:
Well, I was just going to say the one thing
I mean Jonathan raised it but that we re missing
and we re referencing market. But I mean how
many people in this room would have paid money
individually for that photograph? How many
people in this room would pay you know, would
start paying to follow somebody on Twitter?
So this notion that you know, and I know this
is a much misquoted quote that has hung out
there for years. That information wants to
be free. It may want to be free but journalism
is unbelievably expensive. I mean one of our
fellows this year covers Afghanistan for the
New York Times and she s one of, you know,
many people who the Times has there and we
talked about what it takes just to cover that
war for a single newspaper and but that s
the New York Times. I mean they ve got, you
know, a very specific kind of model. It s
under unbelievable stress. They have fewer
people today doing that than they did, you
know, a year ago and certainly then 10 years
ago. But who you know, think about your own
news and information consumption habits and
think about how much of it you actually pay
for. Jonathan Zittrain: And for which Ann
Marie Lipinski: And Jonathan Zittrain: Yochai
is saying perhaps the government should pay
for it. Ann Marie Lipinski: And I just want
and so this is a [0:54:58] [Indiscernible].
I mean Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. Ann Marie Lipinski:
not to but [0:55:00] so you know, you went
to Wikipedia. It told you I was the curator-designate.
Small thing but amplify that kind of error
many times, you know, across the sort of,
you know, information sphere where you re
consuming things; and this idea that there
are people who don t just gather but who vet
and vet and vet. That there s a difference
between that kind of information and things
that are just sort of gathered and exposed
and what it takes to finance those kinds of
efforts and what we re all willing to pay
for that. There is a huge disconnect Jonathan
Zittrain: Yochai Benkler: Can we agree that
for every one mistake in Wikipedia, we have
Judith Miller on Iraq and that that outweighs
many Jonathan Zittrain: My guess is that is
not going to be a Ann Marie Lipinski: Yes.
Jonathan Zittrain: quick agreement. [Laughter]
Jonathan Zittrain: But of course you are looking
for agreement necessarily with that question.
Yochai Benkler: Me? Looking for controversy?
Jonathan Zittrain: But Newt, you want to get
in, so please. Newt Minow: I think you can
learn a lot from other countries and other
cultures. I got very interested in this when
I was at the FCC and I visited Japan. I learned
about the Japanese system and I asked them
why they had that system. They said when television
began, the Japanese sent teams all throughout
the world to figure out which was the best
system and they loved the BBC. So they started
with what was called NHK which is the equivalent
of the BBC in Japan. They wanted to find a
way to use money from everybody but yet, that
it would create an institution that was independent
of the government. It s a real trick. How
do you take money from everyone and yet have
an institution that can criticize being a
[0:57:00] [Indiscernible] of the government.
Well, the Brits did it with a license fee.
Everyone in England must pay if they want
a television set, they must pay X dollars
a year for a license to have a television
set. That money goes into a fund that creates
the BBC. The Japanese have exactly the same
system. In our country, we didn t do that.
We started in so those were the first systems.
BBC started before commercial broadcasting.
NHK started before commercial broadcasting.
We started with commercial broadcasting. We
added, as a footnote, public broadcasting
later without a means to pay it. The Carnegie
Commission, when it created public television,
said everyone who buys a television set should
pay a $5 fee that goes into a fund for public
television. The Vietnam War was on. President
Johnson didn t want to have a new $5 fee forever
so it was dropped. So the result is we have
a poorly-financed system. The question really
to me, the big question is, Do you want the
market to decide everything? Do you think
the market can provide everything or are there
certain things the market will not provide
and if there are, can they be provided by
some alternative system? That we never settled
that in the Jonathan Zittrain: And I guess
the beauty of the license is that it sort
of goes into a lock box. It s not like the
government Newt Minow: Right. Jonathan Zittrain:
changes the appropriation. It s that this
is specifically to support that enterprise.
Newt Minow: Correct, and the BBC Jonathan
Zittrain: Yes. Newt Minow: is often in an
argument with the government on this issue
or that issue and so there is a tension there
but it s a device we never even thought of
in our country. Jonathan Zittrain: I guess
today it would have to be flat screen monitors
or internet access or something. Jonathan
Alter: I just I don t mean to like be the
skunk at the garden party but it isn t happening
anytime soon. Newt Minow: re right. Jonathan
Alter: I mean there s one political party
that their top priority early this year was
getting rid of NPR funding which is a very
small percentage of NPR is Jonathan Zittrain:
Well, it s funny that that hoax email that
has been going around for about a decade,
about they re about to cut PBS, then became
true. Jonathan Alter: Yes. Jonathan Zittrain:
Yes. Jonathan Alter: Yes, and I think a lot
of it will be what you know, Ann Marie is
working on, you know, the non-profit model.
ProPublica is doing some great work in investigative
reporting and a lot of it will be in niche
programming that can make money. Like Fareed
Zakaria has a show on CNN. It s very substantive,
international news and he gets sponsors and
he does well and then make even makes a little
bit of money for CNN. So, you know, there
are ways of working within the four-profit
model and [01:00:00] still do some quality
work. One of the things that s fascinating
to me about was what looks like is about to
be happening is that we you know, even there
s a story in the New York Times yesterday
that the late night scene is breaking apart
and that the Leno-Letterman model is now old
and shows like [01:00:22] [Indiscernible]
or The Cold Bear Report [Phonetic] which are
much cheaper to produce are kind of the future
that it s all getting vulcanized with smaller
considerably smaller audiences but making
money with smaller audiences and your so to
your choice point and you know, there s now
much more choice which is a hugely positive
development. But what worries me about it,
because I always have to look for the dark
cloud, you know, is that I think remember
how everybody used to talk about the digital
divide, you know, and you still hear it a
lot. I think we might be headed for this is
clunky but a kind of a contextual divide between
the Americans who get the vast wasteland stuff,
you know, no context. Maybe they re getting
something in social media. You know, they
re seeing a snippet, a video from around the
world but they re not really getting context
and then elites who have a pretty great choice
of different websites to go to and so, you
know, I m always m very conscious of the fact
that the entire political conversation goes
on among about 10 million people. The total
ratings of the cable networks and the Sunday
shows, you know, in the New York Times and
everybody gets into 10 to 15 million people.
Everybody you know, everybody you talked to.
A hundred and thirty million people vote in
presidential elections, you know. So where
are that other 115, 120 Jonathan Zittrain:
Jonathan Alter: Where are they getting their
information? Jonathan Zittrain: So this Jonathan
Alter: How are they making their decisions?
Jonathan Zittrain: This raises great questions
for which I want to turn to more of our special
guests for insight and on what you ve just
been talking about, Jonathan, I think Ellen
Goodman and Virginia Heffernan might be best
able to weigh in. Ellen, you ve been thinking
a lot about public interest, public information,
funding models, all along that stuff. Feel
Ellen Goodman: And the fact that people don
t want to eat their broccoli. Jonathan Zittrain:
And the fact that people don t want to eat
their broccoli but they still might vote.
So one strategy would be to stop them from
voting but another would be to have them vote
and then that s the end of it and the third
would be to somehow get some broccoli into
the mix. So we have [01:02:45] [Indiscernible]
mics you should be free to use and the representative
of good eating, please tell us what you think.
Ellen Goodman: OK. Well, I wanted to come
back to the point about public media because
public media has sort of been looked to as
the salvation both to produce the broccoli
and also to get people to eat it, somehow
to become more popular than it is; and one
of the things that strikes me is Chairman
Minow said the public broadcasting system
that we have in the US is weak and it was
intentionally designed to be weak. Yet, it
seems to be these weak institutions that we
look to, to sort of solve these market failures
whether it s a problem of curation or a problem
of reporting. So I wanted to pose the question.
So for all the proposals that are unrealistic
but still worth making, as Yochai points out
to invest more public support and the broccoli
producers and broccoli marketers, are these
the right institutions? Can they be reformed
existing public broadcasting institutions
Jonathan Zittrain: You sound skeptical. Ellen
Goodman: that we have? Yes, I am skeptical
although I m a strong supporter of public
media. I don t think that the existing arrangement
that we have, not CPP, not PBS and not NPR
as the strongest public media institutions
are capable of innovating like many large
innovations, they sorry, large institutions.
They are not innovators and it although it
s reasonable to look to these non-market actors
to solve these problems, I don t think these
are going to be the actors. Jonathan Zittrain:
Virginia Heffernan, you ve seen the landscape
both as a student of television. You ve forced
yourself to watch a lot of it and write about
it in the New York Times or elsewhere. Virginia
Heffernan: No forcing. I m a doughnut eater
Jonathan Zittrain: Oh, you re a doughnut eater.
You don t eat the broccoli? Virginia Heffernan:
And I really believe that beta carotene and
foliate is where you find it in the media.
I something on this so, one of the things
that Mr. Minow ve bored him with before [01:05:00]
is the idea that something in this vast wasteland
had an amazingly salubrious effect for entertainment.
We ve been talking mostly about news but television
and entertainment is hugely improved and if
you look at HBO or even Bravo, you see anything
but a vast wasteland now. So, some credit
goes to the you know, the part of the speech
where Mr. Minow says he imagines a time when
all the forces of art, creativity, daring
and imagination had been unleashed. He s not
talking strictly about the public interest
and everybody getting spinach and broccoli.
He s talking about an artistic explosion that
we have actually seen in television in the
last 50. So it s worth giving the communications
technology and the free market a little bit
of credit for that and I know he s a big fan
of Mad Men as I am and probably many of you
are here, which I think wouldn t have been
possible without an environment in which television
is regarded both as an art form and as a public
health hazard. It Jonathan Zittrain: s weird
that it s a television show about a time when
television was terrible. Virginia Heffernan:
And part of the virtue of it is that tension.
So the entertainment side though is not the
doughnut side is not an afterthought. Mr.
Minow also mentioned that after 9/11, there
was no YouTube and that s strictly speaking
true although pretty soon after 9/11, a movie
called Loose Change, that alleged that 9/11
was an inside job brought about by some Jewish
Americans to attack the country and inflame
the CIA or something like that, appeared and
you could watch it on the internet and I watched
it there. Some of us who really liked online
video from the beginning also like to look
at a sordid site called Ogrish that had where
you could see terrorist videos and you could
see ultimately you could see hanging videos
and that s where the Saddam Hussein execution
video washed up after his execution. David
Pogue and I found that video online just as
the New York Times was reporting in Iraq the
way that execution went down. They were interviewing
people outside the hanging room to get details
exactly on what happened and as it happened,
they were misinformed. Our million dollar
bad guy bureau couldn all that money couldn
t tell the story of what happened in that
room where the video told it loud and clear.
Someone in the room had a video camera and
those of us who were undaunted like to look
and liked, for whatever perverse reason, to
look at videos on LiveLeak made by soldiers
and other military personnel. Looked at those
videos and could understand the very night
of the execution, what Saddam Hussein s last
words were where the New York Times reported
them and other places reported them wrong
on the front page. But and I m reading Errol
Morris book right now, Believing is Seeing.
It s a completely fascinating book about some
of the images of the past 10 years since 9/11
and it makes the case more than ever, especially
about the Abu Ghraib images, that contextualization
and criticism and obviously, you know, we
all write from where we sit. A critic is an
extremely important part of this and while
I believe the New York Times has made a great
investment in its international reporting
and that has been the best thing it s done
to show up the brand and also inform the readers,
we also need people to put that new video
lingua franca into context. It s an extremely
difficult language to speak. When you look
at the Abu Ghraib images, are they entertainment?
Are they documentation? Morris does a really
brilliant job trying to tease that apart but
I wouldn t want to be Bill Keller trying to
figure that out the night those images surfaced
and the fact that some many of those images
including some of the images from Iran walked
the line between news and entertainment. It
means that we also need to have our entertainment
caps on. It wasn t a new source that published
that first published the images of the Saddam
Hussein execution. It was a source that well,
I saw it on LiveLeak where you mostly see
escape or car crashes and medical anomalies
and things that teenage boys like to look
at. That s the place that an execution video
turned up. It didn t turn up on PBS. It didn
t even turn up in the New York Times. So I
think we need to be looking at the entertainment
channels. I think entertainment was vitalized
by the Vast Wasteland Speech and we should
be looking at that part of the television,
you know, and also news programming that walks
the line like the [01:10:00] magazine shows
to as a you know, as a source that could be
in the public interest. Jonathan Zittrain:
So this was such a textured and kaleidoscopic
comment. Virginia Heffernan: Sorry. Jonathan
Zittrain: No, totally informative. Virginia
Heffernan: That s because I m exploding. Jonathan
Zittrain: That s amazing. I m just trying
to figure out whether to come out of it happy
or sad. So just maybe one quick follow-up
is do you suppose, right you ve written a
book Magic and Loss: The Pleasures of the
Internet. You re bridging television to internet
and that s just you do in your comment. Is
it the sort of thing for which this ecosystem
is in need of the kind of shaking by the lapels
that Newt Minow did to the television industry
in 1961 or is it that it s going to shake
out and that there s no real grasp for lapels
here Virginia Heffernan: I would love to see
a Vast Wasteland Speech in that moral, poetic
key. I mean the only thing I can imagine right
now and really, I ve been asking everyone
to do this in the question of, Can we do better?
Every single one of you should be registered
as a Wikipedia editor today. So if you haven
t done that, go home tonight. Doris Kearns
Goodwin, if you are not Female Participant:
Twice Virginia Heffernan: Yes. Female Participant:
Twice if you re a woman. Virginia Heffernan:
Twice if you re a woman, exactly. Sign up
your [Crosstalk] [01:11:19] Jonathan Zittrain:
Doris Kearns Goodwin edits the article on
like Abraham Lincoln or Virginia Heffernan:
Jonathan Zittrain: something and then Hotpants15
reversed it [Laughter] Virginia Heffernan:
Yes, exactly, exactly but if you I mean, are
you? Are you? Doris Kearns Goodwin: Virginia
Heffernan: Doris Kearns Goodwin: Even though
I could have been Virginia Heffernan: I mean
this is fascinating. This is the internet
taxes us enormously but this is one way where
we are represented on the internet and the
Wikipedia is the first thing that comes up
when you put in your name Abraham Lincoln
s name into Google and it s edited by might
be edited by Hotpants15 and that I mean, I
can t put it in Minowvian rhetoric but if
I could beseech you to do better, I would
say register as an editor tonight. It s very
simple and Jonathan could talk you through
it. Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. Ellen wants to
get back in but Doris, first, we just have
to ask you. Is there any chance you would
do this? Doris Kearns Goodwin: m really moved
by this. I Virginia Heffernan: Good. Doris
Kearns Goodwin: [01:12:19] [Inaudible] Jonathan
Zittrain: No, no, no. I was going to make
it myself [Laughter] Jonathan Zittrain: [01:12:23]
[Inaudible] on behalf of Wikipedia. [Laughter]
Jonathan Zittrain: We welcome you aboard.
Now it can be told that I am Hotpants15. [Laughter]
Jonathan Zittrain: But I [Crosstalk] [01:12:35]
Jonathan Zittrain: I just want it to be on
the record. Doris Kearns Goodwin: I understand.
Jonathan Zittrain: That Doris Kearns Goodwin
is intrigued and elated to become a Wikipedia
editor. Doris Kearns Goodwin: It is a deal
but if I may add something. Jonathan Zittrain:
Yes. Doris Kearns Goodwin: It comes to what
Jonathan was saying about the Tower of Babel.
What makes me sad when I think about the fact
that in history, communication media was so
important for presidential leadership in so
many ways. I mean I m now living with the
muckraking journalist and Teddy Roosevelt
and there you have magazines who put enormous
money into reporting. Two years, three years,
Ida Tarbell could go reporting about Standard
Oil, Ray Baker about the railroad abuses and
then those reports so mobilized the middle
class that Teddy Roosevelt was able to get
legislation through a conservative congress
because the public pushed the congress. When
FDR comes along with the radio, he s able
to go over the head of the conservative press
who would never have given his message to
the country because of the new radio and because
he had 30 fireside chats and Saul Bellow said
you could walk down a hot Chicago street and
not miss a word of what he was saying because
everybody had it on. Eighty percent of the
adult radio audience was listening. When JFK
gives his Cuban Missile Crisis Speech, they
immediately after he gives it, there s no
[01:13:47] [Indiscernible], no Tower of Babel.
They cut back to regular programming so the
country could absorb that speech and you wonder
now and we keep asking, What has happened
to Obama s communication skills from the campaign
to the presidency? I think the bully pulpit
has lost its bulliness. I mean he gives a
speech as he did on healthcare. Joe Wilson
says, You lie, and then for days we talk about
You lie and not about the speech. I don t
know what we do about the fact that if we
need the public to push the country to social
and political change and leadership doesn
t have the relationship that it once had with
the media to get that country mobilized. That
was the promise presumably of Obama that when
he came in, we were going to have a new progressive
era and I think the whole media thing has
made that difficult and that s where I think
your Tower of Babel is. Absolutely right on
and it just makes me sad because as I look
at history, I just I always want to be optimistic
about it. Jonathan Zittrain: Yes, yes. Doris
Kearns Goodwin: And I m not sure how that
partnership Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. Doris
Kearns Goodwin: is going to work Jonathan
Zittrain: s a real emerging theme here. The
presidents have an astounding amount of diversity
and additional channels for expression and
ways that entertainment can become news and
vice versa; but at the same time, it raises
this Tower of Babel issue where none of us
know how to turn Ann Marie Lipinski: Can I
bring a source [01:14:59] [Phonetic]? Jonathan
Zittrain: Yes. Ann Marie Lipinski: [01:15:00]
have you seen exceptions to that? Doris Kearns
Goodwin: You mean in the current day? Ann
Marie Lipinski: The last handful of years.
I mean sort of at what point do we fall off?
At what point does the bully pulpit start
to disintegrate? Doris Kearns Goodwin: m not
sure I really know. I mean I just think that
what it means is in a certain sense that no
leader is I mean there have been moments,
I suppose, when m not sure. No, I m not sure.
Jonathan Zittrain: Maybe 9/11. Doris Kearns
Goodwin: 9/11 was a moment that was a lost
opportunity. I mean there was a moment when
the country was unified, would have been doing
anything if it had been asked for shared sacrifice,
who could have been mobilized to a Manhattan
project for alternative energy. It could have
been mobilized for more people to join the
army that never were asked to join so the
same kids have to do it over and over again.
So there was a chance. Bush had a moment there
of leadership where the media would have responded,
I think; but then once that dissipated, I
haven t seen it since then really. Jonathan
Zittrain: Ellen, you wanted to get Ellen Goodman:
Yes, I was stimulated by your comment about
shaking the lapels of the internet and, you
know, the Vast Wasteland Speech, you could
shake the lapels of an industry because there
were only a couple of institutions. This again
gets to this sense that we re in a post-institutional
era. The presidency the institution of the
presidency has lost some of its power. I think
all institutions have and I think for policy-making
and media, and as I said, I think public broadcasting
institutions have not been designed to do
what we want them to do. We have to start
thinking about the relationship between policy-making
and institutions and how you do that in sort
of a post-institutional media world and world.
Jonathan Zittrain: Jonathan [Crosstalk] [01:16:39]
Jonathan Alter: If I m not mistaken, Newt,
most of the broadcasters you were addressing
were local, locally on broadcasters, right?
They were sort of pillars of their local communities
who came to Washington for the speech and
owned a local Newt Minow: At that time, yes
and there has been a lot of Jonathan Alter:
Right. Newt Minow: consolidation, right. Jonathan
Alter: So there has been on one level, there
has been all this consolidation under a much
smaller number of companies but there s a
countertrend that I find very intriguing that
they now call hyper local news and it s using
these new technologies to report on something
that will never go out of fashion which is
local news. So, you know, we ve been through
this period of just awful some of the great
newspapers accepted like the Tribune but certainly
off the local television news over the last
40 years and the new technologies and maybe
Patch which is AOL s response to this or some
other means of reimagining local news could
provide some interesting experiments on how
to use the new technology in a good way. Ann
Marie Lipinski: There you know, there s one
trend along these lines so I think really
so we re talking about, Do we reward people
who aren t innovating? There s one there has
been one extraordinary generational change
and I ll use ProPublica as the best example
of this or a good example of this; and that
is to say competition doesn t drive us anymore,
competition to be first or to be only with
a story. This is really a remarkable shift
in the way very good investigative journalists
would think about their work. So in the past,
you wouldn t breathe a word of your story
with, you know, the thought of partnering
which is now a verb. In journalism, it was
unheard of and yet, if you look at what Paul
Steiger is doing with ProPublica, right, so
they ll say you know, a recent example, medial
malpractice. We are going to go out and we
re going to basically create a template for
all these newsrooms who don t have the financial
or the journalistic resources to create these
stories in their own markets. So we re going
to provide free databases. We re going to
provide, you know, long lists of you know,
we re going to FOI records by state. We re
going to make all of this put it online, make
it available to you and actually then, you
know, do workshops or, you know, demonstrate
how you might use this information in your
own market. That is a huge shift in the last
50 years. I mean those broadcasters, you know,
newspapers in those same markets, nobody ever
would have agreed to this; and, you know,
so basically Paul and his colleagues have
said if this kind of journalism is going to
survive and it s as expensive as it is, you
ve got to sort of, you know, change the way
you think about how you re going to apportion
these costs and how you re going to share
the best of this kind of reporting. That s
a phenomenal change Male Speaker: Yes. Ann
Marie Lipinski: in the way journalists think
about their work and really unheard of until
the last couple of years. Jonathan Zittrain:
Well, this may be [01:20:00] a really good
moment to call on a triumvirate in this zone
of I think of it as two FCC commissioners,
two former FCC chairmen and one shadow FCC
chairman. I m looking of course at Reed Hundt,
Kevin Martin and Susan Crawford. Spanning
across political parties and appointments
bipolar as it were and having been through
this incredibly transitional period at a time
of great responsibility and I think it from
Ann Marie s prompting, it raises the question,
To what extent can the government, let alone
a single government commission at this point,
be in a position to make whatever salutary
thing we think ought to happen? s not clear
we have consensus on that. More diversity,
less diversity happen. So, Reed, shall we
turn to you first? Reed Hundt: I think you
should go with beauty and youth first. [Laughter]
Reed Hundt: That s all you need to know Susan
Crawford: I think it s also pearls before
swine Reed says with all these things. So,
I just want to put a moment here about the
political moment. So we have a handsome young
president and his beautiful family. They ve
just been elected and this is Newt Minow s
maiden speech and he rides up to this hotel
and he s going into the lion s den. This is
the NAB he s talking to. They are enormously,
politically powerful and I don t think this
should be called the lost the Vast Wasteland
Speech. I think this is the Better Angels
Speech. This is the speech where he calls
on them to search their consciousness and
think about how they could be doing a better
job and remember who Jonathan Zittrain: And
actually believed that that would happen.
Susan Crawford: Well yes. Jonathan Zittrain:
Yes. Susan Crawford: And remember who he was
talking to. This is a distribution network.
These aren t necessarily the authors of the
content themselves. They re the people making
sure that it reaches each Hamlet in America.
So, fast forward to today, such a speech would
be unthinkable. Cable was just a glint in
Ralph Roberts eyes in 1961. He hadn t started
Comcast yet. He had a lot of fun building
it up. It s now, I believe, more powerful
than those networks were as distribution networks,
as a gatekeeper for the good content or the
bad and the word content itself is laughable.
It must have been to you when you first heard
it. This is programming but it s viewed by
the cable distributors as just content and
they re also in charge of this disruptive
network that Ethan talks about internet access.
Ninety percent of Americans right now go to
their local cable incumbent and they never
compete when they re buying internet access.
So the political bravery of this speech is
unthinkable. Now, hope sinks into misgiving
in our own time. We can t imagine this kind
of calling to conscience to make sure that
there s, you know, elevated programming in
our age. So I just want to pinpoint this moment
and say how exciting it is to read the speech
again and I heard it again today. I listened
to it and they re sort of barely laughing
at your jokes. It s a very nervous group.
Jonathan Zittrain: And [01:23:13] [Indiscernible]
at the White House, of course. [Laughter]
Susan Crawford: And now, more than ever, we
ve got vertically-integrated business owning
both content and distribution where the advertisers
are the clients and we are all the product.
Jonathan Zittrain: But now so that was clearly
pessimistic. That, I got. But the reason you
can t give a speech to that group because
here you are saying, hey, when you look at
the pipes, it s consolidated. Susan Crawford:
Right, but there are only four actors in America
you could give that speech [Crosstalk] [01:23:43]
Jonathan Zittrain: s just that you think they
could not respond to a call to conscience.
Susan Crawford: They have no reason to. Jonathan
Zittrain: [Inaudible] in the room here. Susan
Crawford: They at this point, they really
believe that personal preferences equals good
programming. It s the opposite of what Chairman
Minow was saying in that great speech. Jonathan
Zittrain: Over to Kevin Martin. Kevin Martin:
Well, I think that Susan is right about the
fact that what was truly memorable about the
speech wasn t just the substance but the willingness
to take on the incumbent industry and the
willingness to call on them to do something
more. I think that they were an incredibly
powerful industry at the time and she s probably
right. The other industries today are actually
much more powerful. One of the things I m
struck by with Jonathan Alter up there is
actually Bloomberg today has more correspondents
worldwide than any other news organization.
They actually do even than the BBC and yet,
they currently are unable to actually get
many of their news programs and their news
organizations actually on the cable channels
because it competes with those same vertically-integrated
news organizations. So that s an example of
what Susan, I think, is talking about with
the power by the other distributors locking
out the possibilities of even others to be
providing that kind of a service today. I
think that is in large part because they [01:25:00]
no longer when Newt Minow spoke to them, they
viewed their main business is the entertainment
side and that they viewed the news as what
they were doing in the public interest side.
It wasn t about making money on the news and
I think that s what Jonathan Alter is talking
about is it s fundamentally altered and fundamentally
changed. They now see news as a business in
it of itself so they approach it completely
differently and that s a large part of the
problem. But I guess unlike, you know, Susan,
I probably would end up being a little more
optimistic on the possibility of people calling
out for different kinds of change. I do think
that the commission in the last few years
has made more of an impact on opening up the
distribution side. Maybe not on the content
origination side but I actually think about
Reed Hundt when he was chairman just a few
years ago calling on the broadcasters to change
their model to deliver more children s program;
and that was something that was a very similar
moment, calling on them to change the way
they thought about the children. We can talk
about how effective or ineffective that has
been but it actually did change the model
for them serving children and developing a
new standard for being able to do that. So
I think that it is still possible and unfortunately,
we see too few leaders that are probably willing
to have the same kind of courage as Mr. Minow
did. Jonathan Zittrain: Boy, that passes it
right there to you, Reed. There on the children
s program Reed Hundt: So I have to tell you
about the children s programming. First of
all, this is really Newt s fault because I
was President Clinton s FCC chair and I met
with Newt and he was a beacon and he was an
adviser and he also told me Kevin, you learned
this too. If you re the FCC chairman, you
can actually get to do whatever you want.
So I took that to heart and we decided that
we would have the broadcast industry show
three hours of children s television a week
which was turned out to my surprise, a violation
of the first amendment, an absolute outrage
of this was the public interest and they ran
Warner Brothers ran a TV show. If there s
anyone here who was six years old in 1995,
you may remember there was a show called Animaniacs
and they ran a TV show that did not feature
Reed Hundt but instead a clown named Reed
Blunt. [Laughter] Jonathan Zittrain: Aboard
the S.S. Minnow. Reed Hundt: And the Jonathan
Zittrain: Subtle they are not. Reed Hundt:
The whole show was what a complete fool this
person was and then they filed this with the
FCC as proof that they were complying with
the children s television rules. Anyhow Jonathan
Zittrain: Is that an answer to Kevin s question
on effective versus ineffective? Reed Hundt:
you know, hard cases make bad law but what
I do want to say is that Newt was a beacon
to me as he has been to all the FCC chairs
in these years. I just want to say especially
to the young people here. The thing that he
taught me that I did the best I could to live
up to which is to Jonathan s earlier point.
If you have the privilege to get in public
office, you can t do whatever you want but
part of the job, this is what you told me
Newt, is to figure out who you re really representing
and then go to the people who are on the other
side of those issues and tell them what you
think and don t just try to persuade them.
Actually use the power of law to win because
as you ve said to me maybe you might not remember
this. You said, m not going to remember you
that long anyhow. [Laughter] Reed Hundt: And
what really counts is that you stood up for
something, you know, in your time in government.
Now of course we all remember Newt s speech
which drove Kevin and me crazy. We cold never
figure out any phrase to beat vast wasteland
Jonathan Zittrain: Did you try? Were there
actually Reed Hundt: Yes, I did. I gave a
we had we I didn t tell you this. You didn
t know this. We actually had a contest at
the FCC where I said I would give somebody
a holiday if they could think of a better
phrase. [Laughter] Jonathan Zittrain: What
were some of the candidates? Reed Hundt: Well,
it morphed because of this stupid internet
thing into an online exercise in which people
gave different names to the FCC. Five confused
commissioners, funneling cash to congress
and soon it got out of control. [Laughter]
Reed Hundt: Anyhow, the bottom line is I went
to the NAB which was in Las Vegas in my time
and I gave a speech in which I said we shouldn
t waste the vast land blah, blah, blah. They
had a little sign outside inviting broadcasters
who wanted to come to listen. They misspelled
my name and nobody actually came to the speech.
Jonathan Zittrain: It didn t say Reed Blunt.
Reed Hundt: Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. Reed Hundt:
But of course the reason why times changed
is because of what Susan was saying which
is, [01:30:00] you know, the pendulum had
shifted and you could give the speech at the
National Cable Television Association meeting
today; and in fact, the current chairman,
Chairman Genachowski in that neutrality in
effect did do this to the prevailing media
of the day and said there has to be space
for open content and open discussion. This
is a debate that has only begun and will continue
for years and years and years and let me just
wrap this up with a note of optimism. It he
did this in the same spirit that Newt brought
to the broadcasters association in 1961 because
if I may say so, just to close the loop, it
doesn t matter what media you re talking to.
It mattered that you are talking to the dominant
media and as long as you re addressing your
comments to the dominant media on behalf of
the public, then you re doing your job. That
s what you taught me. Newt Minow: I want to
say a word to the law students. You have three
former FCC chairmen here. All three of us
are lawyers. The current FCC chairman is a
lawyer. Kevin and Julius Genachowski were
Martha s students here at the school. Reed
went to Yale Law School. My point is that
law why are lawyers often chairmen of the
FCC? Jonathan Zittrain: That sounds like a
beginning of a joke. Newt Minow: [Laughter]
Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. Newt Minow: re dealing
with a statute. This is the only government
agency that is regulating a medium of communication
and lawyers who understand the first amendment
understand what a treacherous, painful, sensitive
thing that is. So for those of you who are
in law school, there s a future for you at
the FCC. Jonathan Zittrain: At least for two
years while you can support your family then
[01:32:09] [Inaudible]. Reed Hundt: And if
you went to law school with the president.
Jonathan Zittrain: And if you went to law
school with the president, which could also
be, to those who also aspire, something that
could happen. Ann Marie Lipinski: Could I
ask Newt a question? So we ve had lots of
people, me included, suggest what the better
parts of your speech were. When you were going
into that Newt, did you have a sense of A,
whether it would endure at all and B, if it
would what the kind of you know, what the
critical moment in the speech was. Newt Minow:
Ann Marie, it baffles me to this moment that
50 years after that speech, it is still being
talked about. It baffles me. I paid no attention
to the words vast wasteland . I had a lot
of people helping me with the speech, one
a very gifted writer. He had written vast
wasteland of junk . I crossed of of junk and
paid no further attention to the parts of
that word. I think what you said before was
a good point. The New York Times put it on
the front page and I think that made it a
and I think many, many American people felt
that I was basically right, that television
could do more to serve the public and I think
I got thousands of letters as a result. So
but I did not anticipate this at all. Big
surprise. I think the fact that it was a new
administration, a new president, a new medium,
it was the time and the context; not me or
the speech. Jonathan Zittrain: Kevin Martin
and Reed Hundt have raised the question of
youth and youth programming and of course
Newt, you ve mentioned the youth in the room
maybe looking forward to when their turn will
come to have a crack at issues like these.
It seems natural maybe to call upon John Palfrey
who has been studying generational changes
and how people perceive views, the internet
and the information they might receive and
give over it. To what extent have people themselves
been changing over the years? It s not just
the landscape getting different but people
too, kids. John Palfrey: Thank you, Jonathan
and thank you Chairman Minow for the speech
and the occasion to have this amazing conversation.
I slightly disagree with the idea that that
speech is surprising, that it s so memorable.
I think in fact for those of us [01:35:00]
reading it and rereading it sometime after
you gave it, and I was in the category of
not born when you did, it has multiple layers
to it. Vast Wasteland I think was the easy
headline and then as you noted, you have the
tie between communication technologies and
politics and the public interest, something
I think that many of us it defines why we
do what we do but then it has this third layer
in many areas where you add in to the mix
not just communication technologies and public
interest and politics but children and education.
You have in the speech the line Most young
children today, believe it or not, spend as
much time watching television as they do in
the schoolroom, and which you then repeat;
and it s there when you call upon the people
in the room to search their consciences. It
seems to me that this is an incredibly fitting
thing for you to have called upon, particularly
given where your daughter has ended up and
her husband Joe Singer, both of whom are educational
reformers literally here at Harvard Law School
and who have focused on the use of technology
and video and so forth. s really an amazing
kind of clarion call a long time ago to focus
on the power of these technologies in these
ways and I think the answer is we don t know
the answer, Jonathan, to your question of
how people are changing; but we know the relevance.
We know the fact that in a classroom like
this, it matters a great deal not just the
formal learning that s happening here but
the informal learning that kids are getting
and I actually think that the echoes are amazing
from this speech 50 years ago. It s a real
gift. Jonathan Zittrain: So bracketing the
youth question then, Perry Hewitt, are you
here? Where is Perry? Perry, you re the Chief
Digital Officer of Harvard University. Perry
Hewitt: I am. Jonathan Zittrain: Which so
far as I can tell means you are the one who
exercises the search dark arts to make sure
that we come up on searches for higher education
instead of Perry Hewitt: t mess with me, Jonathan.
Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. So I don t know. Do
you have a sense of reaching out to this generation
through this cacophonous set of media? Perry
Hewitt: I was so struck by something Mr. Minow
said this evening in addition to his landmark
speech where he said the government s job
at that point was to expand choice for viewers;
and I think of today when there are 800 cable
television channels and 48 hours of YouTube
video uploaded every minute. I think one of
the things we need to do both as an educational
institution and as media leaders creating
programming is not only shift the focus toward
creating higher quality programming but also
shift the focus toward making that programming
discoverable and findable. That s a lot of
what I m trying to do here at Harvard, thinking
about creating meaningful collections of the
thought leadership that happens because something
that happens at the law school around 9/11
might be really tied to something that s going
on at the business school and nobody has the
time to make those connections. So that s
our job but when I think about media leadership,
when I think about quality programming, I
think it s as big a challenge to create the
programming now but it s also an enormous
challenge to make it findable and to make
it accessible to those youth who I think are
desperately looking for the quality. Jonathan
Zittrain: And I got to that s exactly the
challenge that Nicholas Negroponte has been
taking up in so many different modes over
the years. More recently and perhaps most
well-known, the One Laptop per Child Program
of trying to figure out how to create information
conduits to and from very far away places
with Nicholas Negroponte: [01:38:20] [Indiscernible]
but you do really good at this. I mean you
re really good. Oh my god. [Laughter] Nicholas
Negroponte: Yes, you [Applause] Jonathan Zittrain:
I can t tell if that s a compliment or not.
Nicholas Negroponte: That s a compliment.
Jonathan Zittrain: But I ll take it. Nicholas
Negroponte: That s a real compliment. I sort
of come from a slightly different world where
we spend less time reflecting and more time
inventing. So I m a little bit of an interloper
here but by chance when I founded the Media
Lab, my partner was in the White House with
you, Newt. It was Jerry Wiesner and he told
me a story very early on when I first got
to know in the 70s about how he brought Vladimir
s work into the White House. I don t know
if you remember the name but Vladimir Sworkin
is generally credited with inventing television.
It was a Saturday and Jerry sent his work
and then I won t try and imitate Sworkin s
but it was a very heavy German accent. He
said, Have you ever met the president? He
said, He said, Well, let s go see if he s
in his office, and he was there and [01:39:22]
[Indiscernible]. It was a Saturday afternoon
and he says, Mr. President, I want you to
meet the man who got you elected. Apparently,
Kennedy said, Oh, you know, how is that? and
he said, This is the man who invented television.
Apparently, Kennedy said, Oh my goodness.
You did such a wonderful thing, and so on.
As Jerry sort of tells that it s working,
looks at him and says, Mr. President, have
you looked at television recently? [Laughter]
Nicholas Negroponte: He said, When we invented
it, we thought we were inventing an educational
[01:40:00] medium. We thought we were inventing
a medium for the arts, and one of the things
I took away from that story was the difference
between television and photography. I m going
to use photography as an example. The people
who invented television were engineers who
then threw it over the wall and various people
used it. People who invented photography were
photographers and the same people who made
the creative content invented the medium and
that s what I think is happening in computers.
That was why we started the Media Lab, to
make a place where the inventors and the creative
users were the same people; and for 25 years,
we ve been doing that and that s the reason
why we from those years. Newt Minow: And do
you come out then as an optimist that while
we are talking and talking policy, you re
out building? Nicholas Negroponte: m well-known
as being A, unrealistic and B, an optimist
about everything so yes, very much an optimist.
Jonathan Zittrain: I can t tell you if you
complimented yourself or not but [Laughter]
Nicholas Negroponte: You haven t been able
to tell much since I was there but yes, I
m an optimist and I m sort of sometimes so
extremely optimistic that you should, you
know, not believe me. [Laughter] Jonathan
Zittrain: Which of course makes you far more
credible. So it s that sort of I mean part
of I think what we ve all been grasping at
so far is capturing the kind of authenticity
that this medium could allow. Maybe it did,
maybe it didn t, trying to elicit it from
the medium and trying to achieve the same
thing today as more and more choices are there
and many of the doors have false ones behind
them and others may have [01:41:47] [Indiscernible]
that otherwise wouldn t come through. We are
nearing the end of our time. We haven t even
had a chance to open it up because to sort
of unpredictable characters because we have
not predictable characters. Predicted characters.
That didn t sound like a compliment at all.
Jonathan Alter: It didn Jonathan Zittrain:
m just trying to make Susan s pearls before
swine comment recede but I just failed at
that too. Female Speaker: You say something
funny, you don t need to be Jonathan Zittrain:
So I don John, I m just going to call on you
real quick as sort of a proxy, given we have
so little time though, for those voices that
haven t been organized ahead of time. You
ve actually had your eye on the Twitter stream
so I hate to have that kind of old CNN moment
where they re like, So what does so and so
in Baghdad have to say? but I m curious. Is
there anything different that has been happening
in response to this online that hasn t yet
found its way to the floor here? John Palfrey:
I was struck that you were actually RT-ing
the comment by Susan Crawford about pearls
before swine in real time but Jonathan Zittrain:
Pearls before swine John Palfrey: Yes. That
s even better, right? Pearls before swine.
There s a huge amount of Twitter traffic on
here. A lot of it actually is of course reflecting
on things happening in the room but also some
wondering what Chairman Minow makes of 140
characters in this sort of short form discussions
on Twitter. So I don t know if there s a way
that this could be one last question back
to the great man but the social media that
has Jonathan Zittrain: Yes. John Palfrey:
been in the back channel of this room and
other rooms that are watching the webcast
are kind of wondering about real time feedback
from you. Jonathan Zittrain: So the last question,
Twitter, threat or menace? [Laughter] Newt
Minow: Well, I would like to make one comment.
I think the more communication, the better.
I would like to thank you for inviting me
today. Fifty years, it s hard to believe you
re still thinking about a speech 50 years
ago. Jonathan who is in my view the Scotty
Reston of today s generation of political
journalists, Ann Marie who has not only won
a Pulitzer but won the admiration of everybody
in her field and we re glad she s here at
Harvard. Yochai, I ve never met you before
today but I read your work and I admire it
and I m delighted that I was invited here
today. I see somebody here who will one day
be chairman of the FCC and when that happens,
I hope you will remember that the two words
in that statute, the public interest, still
have a meaning which too often is easily forgotten.
Jonathan Zittrain: I am pleased then to turn
the proceedings, with you having successfully
not answered the Twitter question, over to
our chairman, Terry Fisher, [01:45:00] to
bring us in for a landing. Terry. Terry Fisher:
So, as many people have rightly pointed out
some extraordinarily rich and diverse discussion,
impossible to summarize. So instead of making
that attempt, I thought I would try to identify
a few of the themes upon which there seems
to be agreement in the room and a few comments
on them. So, it strikes me that the conversation
has revealed the extent to which technology
and it should be emphasized. Social practices
that are enabled but not dictated by those
technologies have are in the process of corroding
some fundamental divides that have shaped
and structured information, entertainment
and our senses ourselves. So, here are the
divides, as I say, just picking up on themes
that emerged in the discussions. First is
that division between public and private,
the reversal of the trend of the 19th century
which was sharp separation of large institutions
into two discreet categories, governments,
institutions intentionally pursuing the public
interest on the one hand and private parties
coordinated primarily by the invisible hand
and nothing more. That division which began
in the early 19th century and hardened by
1900 is now being reversed and the clearest
manifestation is the emergence of extraordinarily
powerful new aggregators and channelers of
information of which Google would be the easiest
example. So in this contest, I would suggest
in response to Ellen. We re not in a post-institutional
world. It s just the most powerful institutions
are changing and they are arising in between
the zone of public and private. Other divides
that are deteriorating fast or that are traditional
divides include that between professional
and amateur, that between speaker and audience,
that as Virginia suggested between news and
entertainment. Always a fuzzy boundary but
blurring ever more so now and finally, it
should be emphasized here, the boundary between
the university and society at large as we
collectively do and should direct our voices
less at our own communities and more out.
So these changes, the corrosion of all these
divides have had all of the speakers seem
to be suggesting both huge benefits and huge
costs. The benefits include the democratization
of the process information and entertainment
production, the collapse of oligopolies and
the reduction of bias of the story that Ethan
is working to undermine. An increase in the
amount of depth and potential for accuracy
exemplified for example by the story of the
Hussein hanging. A dramatic increase in the
direction to return to one of Newt s original
provocations of a free society as opposed
to a closed society manifested in the contribution
contested of the internet and new media to
[01:48:40] [Indiscernible] and the revolutions
sweeping North Africa and finally, the resurrection
of new kinds of communities. We are bulling
alone less often now. Big benefits, huge benefits.
At the same time, there are corresponding
costs that have received a lot of attention
here. They include the fragmentation, the
loss of a coherent culture, the Tower of Babel,
the threat of sacrificing content, context,
at least if Jonathan is correct, for the majority
of people and the superficiality of what Ethan
refers to as the special power of video programming.
So we ve got massive changes underway, partly
technological, partly social, impossible to
stop with some very large benefits and some
very large costs. So, accepting Newt s invitation
to look forward, it strikes me that there
are underway a couple of additional advantages
that have not received too much attention
here and a method that Yochai in his comment
highlighted of ameliorating the cost. The
benefit that we haven t talked about much
is the advantage in changing [01:50:00] the
people who contribute to this now democratized
process of generating information. We focused
on the quality of the stuff they generate
not on what it does to us as producers. So
this new environment is one in which we are
collectively with extraordinary breadth, as
John Palfrey has revealed in his work, producers
of the culture in which we live. We are engaged.
We are no longer primarily passive, one of
the accusations Newt convincingly made in
the 1960s. Semiotic democracy is in part a
virtue because of what it does to us. OK,
that s the extra benefit I wanted to emphasize.
Now, the method of ameliorating the cost that
Yochai touched upon, that he wanted to emphasize,
is we are seeing and could see more of the
emergence of innovated, distributed models
for sifting, vetting as you suggested, curating
and organizing information. They include,
as we have often remarked, Wikipedia. They
often also include in the technological space
collective sites like Slashdot and then they
include within the universities projects the
sort exemplified here by digital humanities
pioneered by Jeffrey Schnapp, which for example
is providing a remarkably deep, new way of
organizing information; some of it video,
some of it non-video about the Japanese tsunami.
A way of gathering information together and
making it widely available that television
never achieved and could not achieve. So,
my hope is that we, focusing on these potentials,
can accept Nicholas spirit of optimism rather
than pessimism, to see that it is in our power
to inflect, not halt the developments. It
may be here a heresy in this room that the
FCC is not the prime mover any longer, recognizing
the rapid emergence and growing power of the
intermediaries and the diminution in opportunities
for genuine, progressive, regulatory change
at the governmental level. That it is the
growing intermediaries of which Google is
only the first where the real power locates
and that s where we should concentrate our
energies and seek ways of moving this environment
in the direction of the public interest. Jonathan
Zittrain: Terry, you managed to give us a
perfect synthesis of everything that happened
and to ask us to shake ourselves by the lapels,
to take up the opportunities that are offered
by this new environment. We now get to eliminate
the divide between speakers and audience as
we thank our special contributors, our respondents,
Jonathan, Ann Marie, Yochai and most of all
Newt Minow and in fact, all three Minows.
We ve learned so much. The School of Minows
Newt Minow: Thank you so much. [Applause]
[01:53:28] gdnf h(gj gd{<N hH<f h(gj h(gj
hH<f hH<f gd{<N gd{<N h{<N hH<f h{<N gd{<N
gd{<N h{<N heX$ gd{<N gd{<N heX$ heX$ h{<N
heX$ h{<N gd{<N h{<N gd{<N gd{<N h{<N hYTx
h{<N gd{<N gd{<N zmzmz zmz`m` hBTx h{<N hYTx
hYTx hBTx h`F\ hZ8w hI)Q hg!j hI)Q hl>d gd7z
hl>d gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z
gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z gd7z hl>d gd7z
[Content_Types].xml Iw}, $yi} _rels/.rels
theme/theme/themeManager.xml sQ}# theme/theme/theme1.xml
w toc'v )I`n 3Vq%'#q :\TZaG L+M2 e\O* $*c?
)6-r IqbJ#x ,AGm T[XF64 E)`# R>QD =(K& =al-
4vfa 0%M0 theme/theme/_rels/themeManager.xml.rels
6?$Q K(M&$R(.1 [Content_Types].xmlPK _rels/.relsPK
theme/theme/themeManager.xmlPK theme/theme/theme1.xmlPK
theme/theme/_rels/themeManager.xml.relsPK
<?xml version="1.0" encoding="UTF-8" standalone="yes"?>
<a:clrMap xmlns:a="http://schemas.openxmlformats.org/drawingml/2006/main"
bg1="lt1" tx1="dk1" bg2="lt2" tx2="dk2" accent1="accent1"
accent2="accent2" accent3="accent3" accent4="accent4"
accent5="accent5" accent6="accent6" hlink="hlink"
folHlink="folHlink"/> PREXY Normal PREXY Microsoft
Office Word Owner Title <b:Sources xmlns:b="http://schemas.openxmlformats.org/officeDocument/2006/bibliography"
xmlns="http://schemas.openxmlformats.org/officeDocument/2006/bibliography"
SelectedStyle="\APA.XSL" StyleName="APA"/>
<?xml version="1.0" encoding="UTF-8" standalone="no"?>
<ds:datastoreItem ds:itemID=""
xmlns:ds="http://schemas.openxmlformats.org/officeDocument/2006/customXml"><ds:schemaRefs><ds:schemaRef
ds:uri="http://schemas.openxmlformats.org/officeDocument/2006/bibliography"/></ds:schemaRefs></ds:datastoreItem>
Microsoft Office Word 97-2003 Document MSWordDoc
Word.Document.8